. Sky-Folgen sind ja in der Regel immer besser, deswegen haben wir eigentlich hier schon mal einen Bonus. Wir müssen uns also nur noch zu 70 Prozent wirklich reinhängen, wie du es so... Was hast du gerade für eine Formulierung benutzt? Reinhängen? Oder was hast du gesagt? Ich sagte voll aufgehen, aber... Rocken, glaube ich, hast du sogar gesagt. Ja, kann sein, dass ich gesagt habe, dass wir das durchrocken wollen, aber ich muss mit der Tür ins Haus fallen. Dieser Podcast nähert sich ja offensichtlich dem Ende. Also dieses Jahr jetzt. Das Projekt Die Podcast-Harpune ist schön langsam ausgeklungen, der ganze Momentum ist weg, das war's. Wir singen nur noch Weihnachtssieder seit zehn Folgen. Ich habe jetzt auch langsam darauf keine Lust mehr, aber es ist ja bald neues Jahr und anders als normale Menschen, die ja sagen die ganze Zeit, gut, da fängt ein ganz, ganz neues Kapitel an, neun Jahr, bin ich der Meinung, nein, das plämmert sich nur aus, es ist halt einfach nur eine Woche, die nur teilt wird von diesem signifikanten Datum Silvester, was man Silvester nennt, aber danach ist es genauso weiter. Was ja auch eigentlich ein gesellschaftliches Konstrukt ist. Genau, eigentlich geht es genauso weiter. Eigentlich ist da kein Bruch. Und deswegen, glaube ich, müssen wir mal eine Woche Pause machen. Diese Woche jetzt meinst du? Nee, nicht diese Woche. Nee, so irgendwie ein Silvester. Ich darf jetzt die Aufnahme abbrechen. Lass uns erstmal Pause machen. Eigentlich war das Podcastprojekt von Anfang an ja als einjähriges angelegt. Wir haben damals gesagt, wir machen ein Jahr. Ich dachte jetzt, du sagst, es war von Anfang an zum Schadern verurteilt. War es auch, aber gut, du hast recht, es war ein Jahr für ein Jahr angedacht und jetzt sind wir da nach einem Jahr und ich weiß nicht, wie ist es bei dir? Ich sag mal so, wir haben die letzte Woche war sehr markant. Wir haben unseren ersten richtigen Shitstorm bekommen, wir hatten unseren ersten Stand-Up-Auftritt, wir haben unseren Shop gelauncht und wir haben die 2000 Follower-Macht über Twitter gebrachen. Das war die krasseste Woche meines Lebens. Es war wirklich die krasseste Woche an der Zeit. Das heißt, auch mal hallo an die 1500 taiwanesischen Bots, die uns gerade zuhören. Hallo, Arigato, Arigato, Kosaimaste, schön, dass ihr dabei seid, hallo. Und natürlich auch an die 1500 taiwanesischen Kinder, die gerade nichts anderes zu tun haben, als unseren überteuerten Plüsch, ehrlich zu stricken. Arigato, Kosaimaste, hola, johli, chikas und chikos. Und auch vielen Dank an die 50 Leute, die uns jetzt entfolgt sind, weil sie es nicht ertragen haben, weil sie plössische Themenwechsel nicht verarbeiten können. Doch mal ein grosses Entschuldigung von uns, besonders von Florentin, der wollte sich jetzt in einer zehnminütigen Gegendarstellung noch bei euch entschuldigen. Ich bin kurz raus. Viel Spaß. Und natürlich auch vielen Dank an die fünf Hörer, die wir diese Woche persönlich getroffen haben im Boing im Comedy Club. Ich glaube, das sagt man alle. Man sagt das boi-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o- sind gespannt. Ihr seid auf der gestrichelten Linie des Spannungsbogen eines Gags gesurft, sozusagen, aber seid der Welle nicht standgehalten und seit ins Wasser gefallen hat, hat leider nicht funktioniert. Ja, was wir nämlich rausgeschnitten haben war, was zu eurem Nachteil wahrscheinlich, haben wir dann diesen Satz von mir, wo ich gesagt habe, das war jetzt ein Teaser auf die nächste Woche, grosse Vergewaltigungs-Special-Folge. Wenn ihr das also gerade hört, dann tut es mir leid, diesen Satz hätte ich vielleicht drin lassen sollen, weil das ist heute die grosse Themenwoche Kindervergewaltigung. Denn wie jeder weiß, die L-Form schreibt man gewöhnlich mit der linken Hand auf der eigenen Stirn. Ja, ich muss ganz kurz was trinken. Ja, trink was. Wir haben nämlich mal wieder eine Skype-Folge. Wir sind tatsächlich heute wieder mal gemütlich bei uns zu Hause. Die Heizung ist auf drei angedreht, schon langsam die ersten Schneeflocken fallen draußen vom Himmel und wir sind wieder heimgekehrt, wir sind nicht mehr im Studio, die ganzen hier, diese ganzen Regler und die ganze Lippe vor ein teures Equipment ist da. Du sagst heimgekehrt, du kennst dich in Berlin kein bisschen aus, fühlst du dich in Berlin zu Hause eigentlich, würdest du sagen, das ist dein Zuhause? Ja, aber nicht wegen der Stadt, sondern wegen den Leuten, weißt du, hier sind einfach Leute, die mir ans Herz gewachsen sind, hier sind viele tolle Gestalten, die Berliner, das ist einfach ein ganz eigenes. Du Künstler hast Pausen, auch im März, das war's. Das sind alle Bekanntschaften. Und meinen persönlichen Starbucks-Barista, den kenne ich auch, das ist ein guter Freund von mir. Er weiß leider nicht, wie du heisst, weil er immer deinen Namen falsch schreibt. Haha, Starbucks. Kann ich euch mal ans Herz legen, um mal diesem kapitalistischen Grosskonzern noch mehr Geld in den Rachen zu werfen durch meine Werbung.
Zwar gebt euch mal bitte beim Starbucks den Red Velvet Cake. Unfassbar, ich weiß nicht, wer von euch die Jim Gaffigan Show da draußen sieht, wo es eine Folge gibt, wo er in einem Hotelzimmer einen ganzen Red Velvet Cake isst und sich gefragt hat,
Hä, Red Velvet Cake, was ist das denn, was ist das? Und das ist unfassbar, das ist grossartig, ich weiß auch nicht genau, was es ist, aber es ist weiße Schokolade mit im Spiel, ich glaube, es sind Rübenfarbstoff im Spiel, es sind roter Kuchen mit weißer Glasur, supergut. Aha, du kennst ja Dinge. Ja, also falls du zu den Feiertagen noch nicht genau bist, also ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, eigentlich ganz geil, weil wir haben heute den 3. Dezember und nee, wir müssen ja so tun, als hätten wir, Moment, wir haben heute den 1. Dezember. Ach, das erste Türchen ist schon auf. Und ich habe das Gefühl, ich weiß auch schon, was in den anderen beiden Türchen drin ist. Wir sollten keine Tweets mehr raushauen, wenn wir aufnehmen. Und das Geile ist, also am ersten Punkt. Wir haben es zweimal bislang rausgehauen, dass wir an einem Tag aufnehmen. Beides, zweimal! Und an beiden Mal haben wir es nicht gemacht, wir haben sich beides Mal angelogen. Ja, sehr gut. Aber das Geile ist, also angenommen, heute wäre der 3. Dezember, dann könnte man ja folgende Aussage tätigen. Ich kaufe mir später noch einen Adventskalender, weil ich noch keinen habe und kann direkt drei Türen aufmachen. Wie geil ist das denn? Ja, gut. Was hast du für einen? Hast du auch so ein Special? Du hast einen After-8 Adventskalender. Genau, ich kaufe mir jedes Jahr einen After-8 Big Ben Tower. Und hast du auch so ein QR-Code-Ding, so was Neumodernes ist, was Hochtechnisiertes, wo jeden Tag... Wie wo dann hinter jedem Türchen ein QR-Code ist. Genau, wo du dann tolle Videos bekommst. Das gibt's auch? Ja, oder du kriegst Gutscheine oder sowas. Dann gibt's auch Rubbellos Adventskalender, wo du jeden Tag was gewinnen kannst, tatsächlich. Ne, so modern bin ich nicht. Meine Tradition ist es immer schön, Adventskalender kaufen, ein paar Tage zu spät, dann drei Stückchen essen, dann auf die Heizung stellen und dann am 4. Dezember merken, oh okay, das ist alles zu einem riesigen Klumpen verschmolzen, dann wegwerfen und dann bis auf nächstes Jahr warten. Nächstes Jahr warten, ist das vielleicht ein Stichwort für ein nächstes Thema? Mal gucken, was Stefan Tingo draus macht. Viel Spaß. Wo du gerade Starbugs angesprochen hast, ich bin neuerdings das rübergegangen, weil ich habe eine Kaffeemaschine, einen Vollautomaten, die mir mal vor ein paar Jahren gekauft. Aber leider Gottes bin ich nicht in der Lage, das instand zu halten, weil es andauernd schimmelt.
Das heißt, auf der Fehlkaufsskala, wo würdest du es einschätzen?
Unter, über deinen Segway oder über deine Topfpflanze, deinen Kammfisch oder wo würdest du es einordnen?
Öfter benutzt als Segway und billiger als Segway, also auf Platz drei, würde ich sagen.
Nach meiner Wohnung, meiner Zweitwohnung, die ich noch nicht bezogen habe, die ich aus Versehen, weil es das Schnäppchen war, auf Sylt gekauft habe. Ja, dieser riesige Villa in Amerika, die wir für 150 Dollar gekauft haben und noch nie da waren. Genau. Ne, ganz ehrlich, das war mir dann irgendwann zu viel und dann bin ich immer gegangen zu Filtercafé, weil das auch irgendwie im Kommen ist. Und seitdem riecht meine ganze Wohnung seit Tagen so wie ein Lehrerzimmer. Ich habe ganz lange überlegt, woher kennst du diesen Geruch? Aber man kann sich ja durch Gerüche sehr gut an Dinge erinnern. Und mir sind schlagartig so Lehrerzimmererinnerungen ins Gedächtnis gespült worden, weil es einfach, die ganze Wohnung riecht einfach so nach Kaffee, dieser beißende Kaffeegerüste, dieses gesättigte. Ja, und so Kaffeeatem auch irgendwie. Also nicht der Kaffee selbst macht, dass der Raum so raucht, sondern durch den Körper eines normalen Mitte-Vierzigers frustrierten Lehrers, durch diese ganzen Stresshormone, wird der ganze Kaffee nochmal angereichert und dann durch diesen Kaffeeatem, wenn man mal sagt so, Frau Meisinger, ich muss Ihnen von einem anderen Lehrer was sagen, dann kommt dieser Odem des Lehrers einfach zurück, so dieser Atem in deinem Gesicht, das ist für mich genau der richtige Lehrerzimmergeruch. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wir sind ja auch so ein bisschen immer auf der Suche nach geilen Werbungen. Und wir haben auch selber schon sehr oft Leuten gesagt, wie sie besser Werbung machen könnten für ein Produkt. Aber ich glaube, ich habe die beste Werbung überhaupt gefunden, die man jemals für irgendwas gemacht hat. Und zwar Radiowerbung, auch was sehr Vergessenes mittlerweile. Radiowerbung, es war nämlich eine Firma, die das Haus ausmisst mit so Infrarot-Kameras, um dann zu sagen, wo man Strom sparen kann. Und ist ja auch eigentlich ein total löbliches Produkt,
damit man selber auch der Umweltliebe
was machen kann und
gucken kann, wo man selber Strom
sparen kann.
Und dann haben die halt Werbung gemacht
und das
fing an mit so einem lustigen Dialog.
Oh, was hast du denn da?
Ja, das ist ein ganz tolles, buntes
Bild von meinem Haus. Oh, so eins hätte ich auch gerne. Ende. Das war die Werbung. Die haben dieses tolle, geile Produkt, was innovativ in Richtung Zukunft denkt, beworben mit einem tollen, bunten Bild von dem Haus, was du bekommst. An wen richtet sich das denn? An die Kinder? Was ist das denn für ein toller, sich bewegender Stahlkoloss, der vor deinem Haus steht? Das sieht ja lustig aus, das will ich auch haben. Ja, dann geh zu Peugeot oder Renault oder was auch immer. Fand ich so lustig. Warum macht man, wie kommt man auf die Idee? Das Coolste, die Marketingagentur wird einfach nicht verstanden haben, für was die da Werbung machen. Und dann dachten die, das Coolste daran ist, so das tolle, bunte Bild von dem Haus. Ich glaube, die haben einfach aufgegeben, die haben gemerkt, das macht keinen Unterschied. Die haben Marktforschung gemacht, die haben gesagt, es ist egal, welche Werbung man macht, solange man den Namen des Produkts sagt, ist alles gut. Kann sein, weiß ich nicht genau. Ich glaube, Seitenbacher ist auch seitdem einfach wirklich die beste Werbung. Weil es einfach nicht so tut, als hätte man irgendwas Cooles zu verkaufen, sondern einfach nur den Namen. Podcast-Ufo, Podcast-Ufo, Podcast-Ufo.
Deswegen finde ich auch die Idee von einem weissen Raum,
wo einfach kurz Pause gemacht wird. Ja, Spoiler nicht.
Wo man halt diese ganzen, ja okay, alles klar.
Dann nicht, mein Gott, dann mache ich halt keinen geilen Content im Podcast raus.
Dann, gut, dann schweigen wir.
Ja, müssen wir jetzt auch schon aufhören.
Denkt euch auch eine geile Geschichte gerade mal.
Mir auch egal.
Wollen wir noch mal kurz eine Schweigeminute einlegen für unser unser Zweitprojekt, die Podcast Zimtschnecke. Ne, für unser... Das leider verendet ist. Für unser, ähm... Da ist die Schweigeminute in meinen Satz reingerutscht. Stephans neue Stil ist einfach das Schnitt Guantanamo. Er macht nach jedem Wort eine vierminütige Pause, um das perfekte nächste Wort zu finden und rafft das dann alles im Schnitt so zusammen. Die Aufzeichnung dauert zwölfeinhalb Stunden. Das wäre mal durch eine Anekdote. Man nennt mich auch Stefan Fiedlein-Podcaster. In der Szene nennt man mich den Fiedlein-Podcaster, weil ich immer nur Fiedleins raushaue im Podcast und dann nachher im Schnitt geile Pointen einführe. Genau, ein gesamtes Comedy-Material durchsetzen. Was hat John Mulaney eigentlich, was würde John Mulaney auf diese Feedline sagen und schneide es dann irgendwas auf seinem Programm rein. Was würde John Mulaney jetzt tun? Das frage ich mich sehr oft. Falls ihr euch fragt, was Stefan getan hat, wollen wir schon zu euch, ich habe die ganze Zeit den Fragen, unser ganzes Setup-Azum-Werlin. Hier ist ein kleiner Einspielfilm, den ich vorbereitet habe, das ist Florentin Will.
Ja, jetzt, lass mal hören, mein Lieber. Das, was im Neo Magazin in vier täglicher harter Arbeit entsteht, improvisier jetzt mal.
Ich mach die Musik. Bielefeld geborene Florian Matthias Wilnorek ist, anders als man vielleicht erwartet, nicht als Klassenclown zur Welt gekommen. Er war damals ein sehr ernster Mensch, der sich in harter Kleinstarbeit ... Und wir sind Neo, Neo, war ja rein. Ich dachte, wir machen jetzt ein geiles Hörspiel irgendwie, so eine Impro-Nummer, so eine Wupp finden. Ich glaube, das darfst du nie wieder denken, Hörspiele sind direkt verboten. Hörspiele und Scheren, das sind die beiden Worten, wo sofort der Filter anspringen und sofort rauspringen. Aber hättest du das gedacht, ganz kurz, hättest du das gedacht, dass so viel geballter, ehrlicher Entrüstung kommen kann, weil man ein Thema anspricht, was nicht jedem passt und es vielleicht nicht korrekt behandelt hat, weil man keinen Scherz darüber gemacht hat in einem Comedy-Podcast. Ja, wir hätten eigentlich einen Scherz darüber gemacht. Das war unser Fehler, dass wir keinen Scherz gemacht haben. Die Leute haben uns vorgeworfen. Ich bin bereit zu lachen, mein Mund ist schon offen, meine Augen weit geöffnet, ich würde jetzt nur gerne lachen, aber da ist nichts. Das war tatsächlich unser Problem. Und er hat jetzt echt nicht gedacht, dass da so viel zurückkommt, aber naja, ich sag mal, man muss eine Community manchmal schleifen, wie eine gute Schere. Wie ein Diamanten. Ja, oder wie eine Schere. Ich wollte das rausschneiden und sagen, wie ein Diamanten. Nein, so kannst du das einfach nicht machen, dass du, wenn wir beide eine Pointe liefern, einfach meine rausschneidest, so funktioniert das nicht. Dieses ganze fucking Geschneide hat wirklich unseren Podcast ruiniert. Früher haben wir überhaupt nichts geschneiden. Da haben wir jetzt überstehen, um zu reden. Nein, da haben wir mal laufen gelassen einfach und haben einfach mal ein bisschen geschnackt, wie zwei Leute es machen. Da war das Tempo nicht so hoch, da war die Gagdichte nicht so hoch, aber es war ehrlich, es war authentisch, da waren echt Emotionen und Gefühle dahinter. Es war nicht immer rund, aber es hatte Charakter, hatte es. Genau, es hatte hier eine Ecke und eine Kante, wo man sich dran gestossen hat, ja, aber gar nicht austauscht war. Und dann mal ganz ehrlich, wir haben dann diese Diskussion geführt, wie wir damit umgehen jetzt mit dem Shitstorm, während ich den meinen Badass-Moment der Woche hatte. Oh geil! Ich war beim Rollhockey. Hey, mega geil! What? Ja! Also ganz kurz, um beim Rollhockey. Hockey, die uncoolste Sportart der Welt, plus was? Rollschuhe. Ah, die uncoolste wirklich Sportbekleidung der Welt. Aber minus mal minus ist plus. Und man denkt sich die ganze Zeit, ich habe die ganze Zeit Kopfhörer ins Ohr gemacht und Starlight Express gehört und es ist einfach perfekt. Es ist nicht so teuer wie Starlight Express, aber es ist genau das gleiche. Erwachsene Männer fahren auf Rollschuhen und bunten Trikots rum und bewerfen sich mit Bällen und dabei haben sie Schläger in der Hand. Mega! Und irgendwie das Geile war daran, ich bin danach nach Hause und haben Leute gefragt, wie hat es dir gefallen und ich habe gesagt, ja, war ganz okay. Aber das Spiel ist sechs zu sechs ausgegangen. Das war also so was wie, ich weiß nicht, wie wenn im Fussball es nachher im EM-Finale acht zu acht gespielt wird. Das ist einfach ein wahnsinnig erstaunliches Ergebnis, sechs zu sechs. Und man kommt nach Hause und sagt, ja, war ganz okay. Das fand ich auch so beeindruckend, wie unbeeindruckend diese Sportart für mich dann war. Es gab 17 rote Karten, ja, war ganz nett. Es gab eine blaue Karte tatsächlich einmal. Eine blaue Karte. Das hat er sich doch ausgedacht. Er wusste doch, dass keiner aus dem Publikum Ahnung hat. Es war echt lustig. Und es gibt Team-Fouls und blaue Karten. Es ist ein bisschen weird, aber man hält fest, es sind erwachsene Männer, die auf Rollschuhen rumfahren und versuchen, ein Tor zu treffen. Total cool, großartig. Ja, ich finde es ja immer so spannend, wenn bei so Sportarten, die man ja als was ganz Festes eigentlich sieht, dann tatsächlich auch die geändert werden. Ich habe mir zum Beispiel letztes Mal, weil ich ein sehr erfülltes Sozialleben habe, die Geschichte des Schachs durchgelesen. Oh yeah, wow, hey yeah, party time und der Pokal zum uncoolsten Leben 2015 geht an Florentin Witt. Also es tut mir leid an alle Hörerinnen, die sich jetzt ihre Unterwäscher wechseln müssen, es tut mir wirklich leid, es war nicht beabsichtigt, aber tatsächlich habe ich gelesen, wie die Schachregeln sich im Verlauf der Zeit geändert haben, so im 18. Jahrhundert irgendwann, wo man gesagt hat, Leute, hier das funktioniert nicht, wir können nicht sieben Spieler gleichzeitig dieses Spiel spielen lassen, wir können nicht die Türme werfen lassen, wir können nicht den Türmen auf den Gegner werfen, das ist eine unkündige Geschichte. Es gibt drei verschiedene Arten von Bällen jetzt im Spiel, man muss würfeln, es ergibt einfach keinen Sinn. Und dann würde es gerne, die Rochade zum Beispiel ist ein sehr interessantes Beispiel, die sehr oft geändert wurde. Ja, die sehr oft geändert wurde. Das ist das nächste Buch, das ich lese, die Geschichte der Fachbegriffe im Schach aussprachen. Die Geschichte der Rochade. Ja, genau. Und ja, es ist sehr spannend tatsächlich, dass sich sowas auch ändern kann, dass man hier immer als etwas Starres wahrnimmt. Ja. Nehmt euch das mal als Vorbild, nehmt euch die mal die Rochade als Vorbild und versucht Dinge zu ändern, die ihr immer als nicht änderbar wahrgenommen habt. Ist beim Eishockey auch so, da gibt es nämlich dann irgendwann Overtime, wenn Unentschieden gespielt wird, weil dann wird der Punkt noch ausgespielt, der Gewinnpunkt. Und in den USA wird das jetzt drei gegen drei gespielt, was dazu führt, dass es unfassbar schnell wird und unfassbar cool wird. Und dann werden jetzt auch Videos rumgeschickt, drei gegen drei ist das Beste überhaupt und so. Also auch relativ moderne Sportarten verändern sich noch, was ich toll finde. So Teamgrösse ist ja relativ willkürlich, so Fußball, ja, elf, Handball, acht, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht mal, sieben. Da kann man auch sagen, nee, komm, wir machen einen raus, Freddy, du gehst raus, wir machen jetzt nur noch sechs, wir machen das immer ohne dich.
Ohne dich, warum? Das ist auch sehr willkürlich, einfach zu sagen, wir hauen einfach noch zehn Leute dazu und gucken einfach mal, was passiert.
Ja, vor allem, ich versuche immer nachzuvollziehen, warum Sportarten so erfolgreich sind, wie sie sind. Und ich bin der Meinung, dass Fußball, das, sehr gut, sehr gutes Thema. Das hatten wir schon, glaube ich, bei der Sendung Sport. Aber auch für die neuen Hörer. Komplett geschnitten worden. Wir holen mal die neuen Hörer mit rein, die gekommen sind, weil sie Kindervergewaltigungsgags toll finden. Wir machen es jetzt immer so, immer wenn wir eine Anekdote erzählen, die wir schon mal erzählt haben, schneiden wir die einfach aus dem alten Podcast raus. Und wir ernähren uns sozusagen von unserem eigenen Körper. Oh, wir sind so Parasiten von uns selber. Ja, genau so Parasiten, wir fressen uns selbst auf. Und ich bin der Meinung, und irgendwann haben wir gar nichts mehr und nur noch die neueste Folge, in der alles als grosser Kristall zusammen komprimiert. Was dann die Best-of-Folge ist, im Jahr 2033. Psst, Mann, du spoilerst aber heute wieder. Oje, und zwar, ich bin der Meinung, dass Fussball so erfolgreich ist, weil es halt die perfekte Feldgrösse hat und weil es so einfach ist, zu verstehen und zu spielen. Und ich bin der Meinung, Sport entsteht ja, glaube ich, um sich einen Ausgleich zu schaffen, nach der Arbeit was zu machen. Und so einen Ball hat man halt schnell und zwei Tore und irgendwo reinschießen ist halt sehr nah, ist halt sehr nah an nichts. Also man kann sehr schnell machen. Und deswegen verstehe ich zum Beispiel nicht. Du hast sehr lange darüber nachgedacht, über das Konzept. Ja, aber deswegen verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz, warum in den USA beispielsweise andere Sportarten erfolgreicher sind. Vor allem wesentlich komplexere Sportarten, zum Beispiel Baseball, das habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden. Ja, genau, was ich verstehe als eine Mischung aus Brennballen. Also vor allem, es wird ja alles darin gemacht in Baseball. Es wird geschlagen, gelaufen, gefangen, gelaufen und geschlagen. Fünf verschiedene Sachen. Und auf dem Boden rumgerutscht noch auch sowas. Was das soll, weiß ich auch nicht. Ja, aber wie entwickelt sich das? Einen Schläger hat man seltener zur Hand als einen Ball wahrscheinlich. Also anscheinend hängt meine Theorie da so ein bisschen. Verstehe ich nicht. Ja, da könnte man jetzt einen lustigen Sketch drüber schreiben, wie Baseball erfunden wurde, dass es immer irgendein historisch trächtiges Ereignis gab, irgendwie in Budapest 1922, wo dann irgendjemand irgendjemand was geschlagen hat. Da könnte man sich was überlegen, aber es ist Donnerstagabend, ich habe da jetzt auch keinen Bock mehr drauf, irgendwas aus den Fingern zu sagen. Du meinst, es ist Dienstagabend? Ah, Dienstagabend. Ich habe das nur das D gelesen, deswegen. Du, was ist bei dir in der Woche? Du bist so ein Weihnachtsmensch, oder? Du bist hier jemand, der Weihnachten lebt. Du hast ja bestimmt auch für fünf Leute mindestens schon deine Geschenke zusammen. Hast du dich auch schon verpackt? Du bist ein Verpacker, ne, Michael, ein Verpacker. Ich habe mir heute mal überlegt, dieses Jahr, glaube ich, bestelle ich meine gesamten Geschenke, einen Satz, der vor 15 Jahren vielleicht angemessen wäre, heute vollkommen normal ist. Und zwar bestelle ich alle meine Geschenke im gleichen Shop, und zwar bei Spreadshirt.de slash das Podcast UFO. Shop. Spreadshirt.de slash Podcast UFO. Spreadshirt.de slash Podcast UFO. Spreadshirt. Spreadshirt. Spreadshirt. Spreadshirt. Spreadshirt. Spreadshirt. Spreadshirt. Spreadshirt. Spreadshirt. Spreadshirt slash sweatshirts und da bestelle ich mir ganz viele tolle T-Shirts und Tassen und Becher und was auch immer. Ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie in einem Paralleluniversum wir in noch dümmer da sitzen und gerade die Internetadresse sweatshirts.de anpreisen. Oder wie wir in einem Paralleluniversum in kleine Plüschbären reden und uns Mikrofone aus dem Shop bestellen oder sowas. Oder in einem anderen Paralleluniversum, was ich für den persönlich viel cooler finde, wo zwei Weihnachtselcher sitzen, den Podcast moderieren und Menschen anmoderieren, die sie mal bestellen können jetzt auf der neuen Seite. Oder zwei Stühle auf Menschen sitzen, die den Podcast moderieren. Ja, Kinder, uns gehen die Ideen so schnell nicht aus, freut euch auf ein erfolgreiches Jahr 2016. Das wird richtig geil. Nochmal richtig los, wir fangen nochmal ganz von vorne an. Das wird richtig toll. Nein, lass uns doch jetzt einfach mal unseren, den, den, den. Lass mal jetzt den Sendeablauf durchgehen. Da fehlen auch die fucking Rorte jetzt hier auch. Den, nicht Kür, sondern. Ich habe übrigens mir gerade nochmal die Limo gekauft. Die Limo. Die Limo, für die Joko und Klaas Werbung machen. Die habe ich mir gekauft nochmal. Weißt du, weißt du, du sagst immer, Stefan macht wieder einen Fehlkauf gemacht und so, aber das lasse ich mir auch nicht sagen, weil manchmal, unter diesen vielen Fehlkaufen sind auch ein paar Sachen dabei, die ich mittlerweile in mein Leben geholt habe, wo ich dann den Arm gross gemacht habe und Leute reingeholt habe in mein Leben und Produkte. Und nur wenn man viel probiert und auch viel scheitert, kann man auch viele Sachen richtig machen.
Und die Limo ist toll. Von Granini.
Granini.
Endlich, Granini.
Jetzt könnte man, was wäre eine gute Werbung für Granini? Granini, wenn sie sich dann immer Flüssigkeiten in Plastikbehältern kaufen wollen.
Zu sich nehmen wollten, um nicht zu verdursten.
Genau, Granini, um nicht zu sterben. Wir machen flenswichtige Flüssigkeiten. Können aber auch jede andere Flüssigkeit trinken. Ist glaube ich ein Family-Gag. Drink it, then make it to pee. Drink it, then convert it to pee. Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Anmachspruch, so hey, wollen wir was trinken, sonst verdurstest du. Naja, also, man sieht die verschiedenen Elemente. Wow, ist ein bisschen eingeräuscht, der Floriditz-Anmach-Organ. Habe ich das letzte Mal im Alter von acht Jahren benutzt, den Gag. Tatsächlich hat auch damals nicht so gut funktioniert, auch bei Stephanie, aus der Parallelklasse, sie war so hübsch in dem kleinen Kleid, was ich mir letztens überlegt hatte. Ich habe tatsächlich in der Schule, weil du halt schon angesprochen hast, ich war ein sehr ernster Schüler, und das stimmt, das möchte ich nochmal aufgreifen, ich habe eigentlich den ganzen, ich habe viel aus dem Fenster geschaut und ich weiß auch ganz genau, einmal ist ein Vogel gegen das Fenster geflogen, allerdings habe ich genau, was das passiert ist, nicht aus dem Fenster geschaut. Du hast die ganze Zeit aus dem Fenster geguckt, weil du gehofft hast, irgendwann passiert mal was Geiles, was ich nicht verpassen werde, aber alle anderen. Und dann läuft Stefanie auf der anderen Seite bei der Tür von der Parallelklasse vorbei, ich gucke kurz zu Stefanie und dann plötzlich, was? Und ich gucke zurück und nein, wie gut das aussehen muss, weil man sieht den Vogel ja schon von ganz weit kommen, so man sieht ihn von ganz weit, da ist ein Vogel und er kommt näher und näher und oh mein Gott, wo will der hin, oh mein Gott, näher will der zu mir, was ist denn da los und watz direkt auf eins. So cool, oder? Und dann habe ich mir auch gedacht, weil man es ja dann an so vielen Fensterfassaden so Aufkleber gibt von so Vögeln, und dann dachte ich mir auch, das ist ein bisschen makaber, oder, dass man gerade da an diese Fensterscheiben diese Vogelsticker macht, wo die halt ständig dagegen fliegen und sterben. Ich dachte mir, das ist so ein bisschen, wie wenn man auf die Autobahnen so Sticker von Igeln und Füchsen oder sowas macht, die da ständig sterben. Aber das hast du jetzt nicht verstanden. Das ist das grundlegende Konzept dieser Sticker nicht verstanden. Ja, das war auch der Gag. Wenn das der Gag war, dann tut es mir aber leid. Dann tut es mir leid für diesen Podcast und dann sollten wir den jetzt in diesem Moment beenden. Weil wenn das dein Angebot des Gags war, ich meine, ich fand die Idee nicht schlecht, aber es ist eine falsche Prämisse. Und wenn die Prämisse falsch ist ... Ja, aber das ist doch der Gag, dass die Prämisse falsch ist. Naja. Mein Gott, du musst jetzt nicht hier jeden Gag auseinanderreißen, was ist da los? Nee, ich wollte einfach nur jetzt mal den berechtigten Einwand bringen, dass diese Sticker ja dazu da sind, dass sie da nicht sterben. Und dein Gag war jetzt zu sagen, dass man die genau da aufhängt, wo sie sterben, aber das stimmt ja nicht, weil die ja nicht da sterben, wo die Sticker sind. Es war noch nicht mehr wirklich ein Gag. Ich habe mich nur daran erinnern, dass ich mir als Kind gedacht habe, es ist ein bisschen makaber, dass man die da genau dahin klebt, wo die sterben. Und habe aber nicht so weit gedacht, dass die da vielleicht hängen, damit die eben nicht sterben. Darauf wollte ich nur aufmerksam machen. Ich dachte, das wäre so ein Ding, dass man wie wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Kunstschnee auf einen Tannenbaum tut, weil ja in der Natur Schnee auf Tannenbäumen ist, dass man aus dem genau dem gleichen Konzept heraus tote Vögel an Fensterscheiben malt, weil die ja da ständig dagegen fliegen. Das war mein Gedanke, so ah ja, okay, um es realistischer zu machen, macht man da Vogelleichen an die Fensterscheibe. Aber auch gut, dass du auch wieder so makaber denkst, dass diese simplen schwarzen Sticker Vogelleichen sind. Ja, und dann habe ich mir, der Gedanke kam jetzt als Erwachsener, dass man vielleicht immer an die Stelle, wo ein Vogel hinfliegt, dann so einen Aufklärer macht, so als Kill Count, so ein bisschen, vielleicht um Vögel abzustrecken, so, don't fuck with us, don't fuck with the window, man, you can't win. Ich finde auch, man sollte diese Linien um Leichen, diese weissen Linien, nie wegmachen. Weil ich finde es total spannend zu sehen, wie viele Menschen schon an dem Ort gestorben sind, exakt wo ich gerade stehe. Das ist ja auch Zeitgeschichte. Es geht doch im Prinzip nur um Leben. Es geht im Leben nur um Leben und Tod. Eigentlich. Und deswegen würde ich gerne sehen. Und Granini. Und Granini. Und deswegen würde ich gerne sehen, wo Menschen sterben, genau. Und woran? Das kann ja da drinstehen. Wenn man vielleicht noch so ein kleines Bildchen, den Dolch noch so draufmalt, woran er gestorben ist. Ja, das ist ein ganz gutes Bild. Könntest du vielleicht in deinem nächsten Stand-Up-Programm verreden? Apropos Stand-Up, was war das? Erstmal danke an den Leuten, die wirklich da waren. Ja, um es noch zusammenzufassen. Wir haben ja damals, glaube ich-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i Programm geschrieben für Maxi Stettenbauer, das hat dann zum ersten großen Debakel geführt, dann bei Luke Mockic, haben wir weiter überredet und jetzt ist es tatsächlich endlich passiert, wir haben allerdings es nicht mehr tatsächlich veröffentlicht, weil wir nicht wollten, dass Leute kommen, weil wir Angst hatten und uns geschämt haben. Ja, ich habe auch sehr viele Leute ausgeladen noch, ganz spät. Also aktiv angeschrieben, du folgendes, ich trete morgen auf, komm bitte nicht. Folgendes, ich kann morgen doch nicht, ich habe spontan abgesagt, und so ganz offensichtliche Lügen habe ich verbreitet, aber es sind dann am Ende doch ein paar gekommen, fand ich aber äußerst nicht schlecht. Ich fand es, glaube ich, sogar ein bisschen besser, als wenn da jetzt niemand da gewesen wäre, der einen sehen wollte. Ja, aber das waren die absoluten Hardcore-Fans, also dann nochmal große Props an alle, die da waren. Vielen Dank. Ja, danke an alle, ausser an die Creeps, die nachher noch unsere Dünnerbude verfolgt haben. Genau, da möchte ich noch mal sagen, so geht's nicht. So geht's wirklich nicht. Und tatsächlich, mich haben noch ein paar Leute angeschrieben, die gesagt haben, sie haben sich nicht getraut, uns anzusprechen, aber trotzdem da waren. Ja, was natürlich die Frage aufwirft, waren da überhaupt normale Menschen anwesend tatsächlich oder waren es alle so inkognito Podcast-Uvo--Hörer, die so einen geheimen Ohrring tragen oder so ein Tattoo auf der Hand haben?
Ja, genau, wollte ich ja sagen, wir haben schon gesagt, es wäre geil, wenn Podcast-Ufo-Hörer sich, ohne sich zu kennen, zu erkennen geben.
Und deswegen fänden wir es ganz geil, wenn die irgendwie so ein Mal hätten, so ein schwarzes Tattoo oder so, irgendwie, weiss ich nicht, so eine Ziffernkombination, sie sich einfach so zeigen, dann einfach bedächtig zunicken und dann ihre Tätigkeiten fortführen. Finde ich sehr geil, ein sehr gutes Bild. Kümmer euch da mal vielleicht drum. Ja, wir dachten, dass wir vielleicht beim nächsten öffentlichen Auftritt einfach, dass sie das T-Shirt machen, dass sie das T-Shirt tragen sollen, aber natürlich wissen wir um unser Klientel, sind alles schüchterne Jungfrauen, die nicht angesprochen werden möchten. und deswegen würden die dann natürlich ironisch ein anderes T-Shirt tragen, dann ein Radionukulart-T-Shirt tragen. Und dann wieder ironisch, doppelt ironisch dann doch ein Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirt tragen oder das weisse Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirt, was sich tatsächlich sehr gut verkauft. Ja, es ist unser Bestseller. Dafür nochmal, dass ihr uns unnötig Geld in den Rachen werft und die Ausbeutung von kleinen Kinderhänden unterstützt, damit ihr ein weisses T-Shirt habt. Geil, finde ich richtig gut. Auch als Weihnachtsgeschenk super gut zu haben, einfach der Oma ein weisses Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirt schenken, das es völlig unbedarft im Bingo-Club trägt und eigentlich indirekt Werbung für unseren Podcast macht und es gar nicht weiss. Das finde ich gar nicht und es beißt. Ich finde das so lustig, wenn Leute sich ironisch dieses weisse T-Shirt kaufen mit dem weissen Logo drauf und irgendwie es so Situationen gibt, wo man das aber erkennt.
Zum Beispiel ...
Oder wenn man das unter so ...
... schönen, weissen Hemden trägt, zum Beispiel,
auf Hochzeiten oder so was, und man dann im bestimmten,
wenn das Licht bestimmt fällt,
man dachte, man zieht sich einfach ein neutrales T-Shirt an,
aber wenn das Licht bestimmt fällt auf der Tanzfläche,
sieht man darunter dieses Podcast-Ufo-Logo-Shine oder so.
Ey, ich hab die Idee, die das Podcast-Ufo-Wet-T-Shirt-Contest-Parade. Das ist doch geil, weil wenn das T-Shirt nass wird, da wird sich das ja abzeichnen. Mega gut. Also ideal für den nächsten T-Shirt-Contest. Mega gut. Das heißt, falls ihr noch nicht wisst, was ihr Mama oder Oma schenkt, falls ihr die Slackline irgendwie vom letzten Jahr noch nicht mehr habt, schenkt ihr einfach so ein T-Shirt und sagt, geh mal zu Onkel Karl.
Aber wie fandest du diesen Abend, also diesen Stand-up-Abend, wo du noch wahrscheinlich oft in deinem Leben dran zurück, also solltest du da zumindest in die Richtung gehen, Stand-up-Comedian, wird das ein Abend sein, wo du noch oft dran zurückdenkst und findest du es war ein Abend, wo du oft dran zurückdenken willst? Ja, das erste Mal vergisst man nie. Und ganz kurz, wir haben es ja auch aufgenommen, ne? Also alle, die sich jetzt fragen, oh, scheiße, dass ich nicht dabei war, warum habt ihr nichts gesagt, was soll das? Ihr werdet es gleich im Anschluss hören, tatsächlich, aufgezeichnet mit allen, ich sag mal, Lachern, die tatsächlich vom Publikum kamen, aber tatsächlich, aus einer Metaperspektive war es leider sehr unlustig alles, weil es ganz normal war eigentlich, wir haben weder komplett versagt, noch haben wir irgendwie mega abgeräumt. Eigentlich war es, wie man es nicht erwartet hat. Wir sind da raufgegangen, haben ein paar müde Gags erzählt, ein paar Leute haben gelacht, Stefan hat tatsächlich ein paar richtig grosse Lacher bekommen. Ja, aber ich habe auch ganz viele Blogs vergessen. Und was im Nachhinein vielleicht besser war, ich habe meinen ganzen Harry Potter-Part vergessen, weil aber Harry-Potter-Gag einfach gar nicht angekommen ist. Vielleicht hab ich dann unterbewusst gedacht, okay, cut it, cut it, lass Harry Potter da raus.
Vielleicht ist es besser, wenn wir das jetzt einfach erst einspielen und dann drüber reden,
weil dann wissen die Leute auch, wovon wir reden.
Wollen wir das jetzt einspielen?
Deswegen, jetzt viel Spaß!
Ich jetzt?
Ihr hört erst Stefan und dann meinen Auftritt, viel Spaß mit unserer Entjungferung im Stand-Up-Bereich.
Sponsored by Granini.
Viel Spaß.
Und Booster Angie Drinks.
So, wir kommen jetzt zu dem Lieblingsteil meiner Show, die sogenannten Open Spots.
Das heißt, man kann sich einfach bei mir melden und dann darf man fünf Minuten hier auf die Bühne und da haben wir heute ein Paar.
Und ich freue mich direkt auf den ersten, der kommt aus Köln. Hier ist für euch Stefan Titze!
Titze, Titze!
Herr Ruster, hi! Mein Name ist Stefan, das Pfann steht für Spaß. Ja, ich mache das jetzt zum ersten Mal und irgendwie hoffe ich, dass wir jetzt irgendwie, das ist für beide Seiten besser, wenn wir das irgendwie durchsehen, einfach. Also viel Spaß mit den nächsten fünf Minuten. Ich habe neulich gelesen, dass das Wort Einhorn neunmal in der Bibel vorkommt. Neunmal um das Wort Einhorn in der Bibel vor, Super Mario glaube ich nur zweimal. Und da habe ich, also die Leute sind auf mich zugegangen und haben gesagt, nein, nein, beruhige dich Stefan, beruhige dich, komm runter, es ist nur ein Übersetzungsfehler. Nun dachte ich mir erst, okay, gut, es ist nur ein Übersetzungsfehler, aber Moment mal, macht es das wirklich besser? Weil ich meine, es ist die Bibel, also Leute, die im Relativ ernst, was in der Bibel steht, wenn es nur ein Übersetzungsfehler ist, vielleicht sollten wir grundsätzlich noch mal darüber nachdenken, wie professionell das damals abliegt, dieses Übersetzungsprozedere. Ich meine, er wird jemanden gesessen haben, irgendwie an seinem Papyrus, Duden, weiss ich nicht genau, was er hatte, und mir überlegt haben, ähm, Moment mal, Jesus ging übers, was kann das heissen, Wasser oder Sand? Ach, nehmen wir Wasser. Ich meine, was hat er denn gedacht, was er wieder übersetzt, dass er auf Einhorn kommt? Keine Ahnung. Naja, und ich finde, im Grunde genommen ist die Bibel noch eine Art Zaubergeschichte. So einfach ein paar random Superkräfte ist eine Art Zauber. Deswegen glaube ich, dass wenn J. K. Rowling sich etwas mehr beeilt hätte und wie es schneller geschrieben hätte, dann würden wir heute alle dem heiligen Harry Potter beten. Und es wäre mega geil, dem heiligen Harry Potter zuzubeten. Ich meine, die Krügererste werden auch keine Kreuzführer geführt, sondern Blitzkriege, na ja, schlechtes Beispiel vielleicht, was ist, schlechtes Beispiel. Es gibt auch noch andere geile Geschichten, vor allem gibt es geile Geschichten aus Deutschland, was das ganze Gute-Nacht-Geschichten ein bisschen angeht.
Das ist ganz geil, aber da gibt es, kennt ihr den Sprügelpeter? Ja, den kennt man. Der ist ziemlich geil, unzimmig brutal, typisch deutsch, eigentlich ganz geil. Und da gibt es diesen Part der Daumellutscher.
Und der Daumellutscher beginnt, und das ist kein Scheiss, mit der, die zu ihrem Kind sagt, dass so ein Kind sagt, ich bin kurz weg, mach keinen Mist, warte hier, lutsch dich am Daumen, tschau und geht. Er machte erpaft jetzt nicht, was jetzt passiert. Er machte er, es ist genauso, als würde ich sie sagen, ich bin kurz weg, mach keinen Scheiss, liess mich im Tagebuch deiner Schwester, dass ich meinen zweiten Schubladen von oben befinde, ich bin in genau 15 Minuten wieder da, tschüss! Das ist genau das Gleiche. Was erwartet Sie? Das sind diese Dinge, die dann passieren, was man zum ersten Mal macht. Man weiss nicht mehr, was man sagen wollte. Der Daumelutscher. Der Daumelutscher, genau. Wie geht es nämlich weiter? Das ist nämlich sehr interessant. Natürlich lutscht er am Daumen, natürlich. Und was nicht so ganz erweitbar ist, dann kommt nämlich ein Mann, ein bildfremder Mann, irgendwie in die Wohnung, mit einer Schere und schneidet dem Jungen beide Daumen ab, gut, Chaos, Trend, Deutsch, yeah! Und dann, das Leile ist, dann kommt die Mutter und, natürlich besonders, es ist kein schätze, die Mutter kommt rein und sagt, tja, ich hab's dir ja gesagt. Klar, wie die Mutter halt so reagiert, wenn der Sohn ohne Daumen und den Bogen zum Beispiel steht. Klar, was soll sie uns machen, ich hab's dir ja gesagt, ja. Und dann sagen alle, ja, aber die Lehre, die Lehre, die man da aussieht, die ist so toll, lutscht nicht am Daumen, ja.
Und da gibt es vielleicht mal dieses Problem, den wir, dass wir offensichtlich im Irren in der Nachbarschaft rumlaufen haben, der Kinder attraktiert mit einer Schere.
Das war gar das Problem. Das war es von mir, der Stefan Kiesel. Wie gross war die ... Ich habe das noch nicht gehört bis jetzt. Ich habe mir das zum ersten Mal noch angehört, und ich finde das so unangenehm, aber es ging. Es war eigentlich genau wie meine Erinnerung. Ich muss tatsächlich sagen, ich hatte die Lacher mehr in Erinnerung tatsächlich. Und deswegen habe ich jetzt auch ein bisschen Angst vor meinem Teil. Weil ich weiß nicht, ich hatte eigentlich schon gedacht, das läuft ganz gut, aber richtig gut. Aber wo wir tatsächlich, wir hatten uns im Vorhinein unsere Programme gegenseitig vorgespielt. Mega awkward, standen wir in meinem Wohnzimmer im Erdgeschoss und haben uns gegenseitig, weil wir völlig nervös waren, unsere Teile vorgespielt, was noch uncooler ist, als von der Masse zu machen. Naja. Mega uncool. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, Alter, der Blitzkrieg-Gag, der wird einen Applaus geben. Der ist echt gut, nicht schlecht. Harry Potter, wir führen gerade Kreuzzügen, Blitzkriege, schlechtes Beispiel. Das ist ein richtig geiler Gag. Und da war dann wirklich so, er macht ihn auf der Bühne und wusch. Vor allem, ich hab das Programm ... Die ganze Luft verlässt den Raum.
Ich hab das Programm einem Freund geschickt,
der auch vor ein paar Wochen sein erstes Mal im Boi-ing-o-yo-yo-ing hatte.
Und der hat auch gesagt, es wäre ein super Gag.
Du hast gesagt, es wäre ein super Gag.
Meine Erwartungshaltung ist ins Unermessliche gestiegen bei diesem Gag.
Und es war der schlechteste.
Und es hat mich so rausgeworfen.
Danach kam noch ein riesen Harry Potter Teil,
den ich einfach komplett vergessen habe.
Aufgrund meiner Furcht dann.
Krass.
Ich stehe auch nach wie vor hinter dem Gag. Ich glaube, das Publikum hat ihn nicht hundertprozentig verstanden. Vielleicht hätte man mit dem Blitz noch mal, dass der Blitz ... Ich habe vorher den Blitz gezeigt tatsächlich, visuell, aber es kam vielleicht nicht an. Aber ich stehe weiter hinter dem Gag und werde ihn auch nochmal machen. Ich glaube, als Tweet hätte der mega gut funktioniert, hätte er richtig viele Erfolg bekommen, weil man halt einfach gut nachvollziehen kann und man drüber nachdenken kann. Aber im Stand-up glaube ich ist es ein bisschen, man ist da vielleicht manchmal zu schnell fürs Publikum. Ja. Das Publikum an sich tatsächlich war tatsächlich auch sehr, sehr willig tatsächlich zu lachen, weil ich dachte, okay, erstes Mal Stand-up, bestenfalls werden ab und zu ein paar Leute lachen, schlechtestenfalls halt stille. Ja, genau. Und ich habe mir wirklich halt vorgegangen, dass es wirklich ein absolut realistisches Szenario ist, dass die fünf Minuten lang schweigen und ich halt einfach rede für niemanden und dann gehe und tschau. Ja, habe ich auch in der Regel, um zu. Aber, ähm, und habe mich auch schon damit abgefunden, auch so ein paar Gags zu machen, zu dem Thema, dass niemand lacht. Also man versucht ja auch vorher alle Szenarios, die man sich ausdenkt, auch gerade in so einem kleinen Club, wo man auch noch schnell mal Leute hat, die dazwischenrufen, da überlegt man sich schon bei jedem Szenario Dinge, wie man da auf Dinge reagiert, um nicht uncool zu wirken und um die maximale Awkwardness irgendwie zu überspielen mit Sprüchen, die man sich vorher zurechtlegt. Aber im Endeffekt musste man davon nichts machen, weil es hat weder jemand reingerufen, noch war es wirklich schlecht. Aber der Scherenmann kam richtig gut an. Die Leute lieben Scheren einfach. Das ist einfach ein geiles Thema. Die Leute lieben das. Vor allem, wenn man Daumen abschneidet, ist kein Problem. Ja, dann ist es wieder lustig. Ich hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die Leute, also haben deiner Meinung nach die Leute an den richtigen Stellen gelacht. Ja. Was sehr gut ankam, war dieses Deutsch, dieses Tränen, Trauer, Blut, Deutsch. Habe ich in der Tat improvisiert, also das ist mir da eingefallen. Ja, das habe ich mir nämlich auch gedacht, weil beim ersten kam es ja richtig gut an, so typisch Deutsch, da hast du einen überdurchschnittlichen grossen Dacher bekommen, weil das halt einfach so ein Thema ist, glaube ich, mega gut zielt, so haha wir Deutschen. Voll interessant, wollte ich gar nicht machen diesen Gag, aber manchmal sagt man einfach Dinge, weil man lernt es ja nicht komplett eins zu eins auswendig, sondern man lernt sich so Brücken zu bilden und so Sätze, natürlich legt man sich zurecht, aber manchmal rutscht einem da noch so was rein, das man gar nicht unbedingt drin haben wollte, was man vielleicht sogar bewusst nicht machen wollte, aber man hat schon mal darüber nachgedacht und deswegen sagt man es dann in so einer Nervositätssituation, das ist auch ganz gefährlich. und dann habe ich das gesagt und es hat Lacher bekommen tatsächlich. Genau, und das sagte ich mir nämlich, dass du dann beim zweiten Mal, wenn du sagst, er hat es abgeschnitten, tot, blut, dass du es dann nochmal raushaust, weil es gute Lacher bekommen hast. Also, dass du den Flow des Publikums richtig erkannt hast und darauf eingegangen bist und in den Gag gegeben hast. Du hast ihnen genau das gegeben, was sie wollten. Ja, nicht so bewusst, aber kann sein, dass es noch geholfen hat. Ich fand schon, dass sie an den richtigen Stellen gelacht haben. Also das war tatsächlich eine Stelle, wo ich dachte, okay, hätte ich ihn nicht erwartet. Dann der Scherenmann hat mich sehr gefreut, den habe ich ja bewusst als Ende getan, weil ich den auch ganz gut fand. Und am Anfang der mit dem, mit Jesus kam er auch ganz zugehe. Die Leute lieben Jesus einfach, das sind deine Themen, Jesus, Harry Potter und Scherenmann. Habe ich auch gedacht, weil man versucht ja beim ersten Mal, versucht man ja irgendwie Themen zu machen, mit denen man irgendwie, wo man sagt, da stehe ich hinter. Das sind deine Themen, Jesus, Harry Potter und Scheren. Habe ich auch gedacht. Beim ersten Mal versucht man ja irgendwie Themen zu machen, mit denen man irgendwie, wo man sagt, da stehe ich hinter, das sind meine Themen, für die interessiere ich mich. Ich will als der Comedian bekannt sein, der über diese Themen Scherze macht. Und im Endeffekt hatte ich vor mir dann Stand-up über Jesus, Bibel, irgendwie Harry Potter und irgendwie Gute-Nacht-Geschichten, wo ich mir dachte, das hätte ich niemals drauf bekommen, dass ich der Typ bin, der gute Nachtgeschichten Gag macht.
Ja, aber es ist halt dein Stil.
Naja, aber im Endeffekt war ich doch zufrieden, auch jetzt vom nochmal hören.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst, weil ich habe mir meinen Teil noch nicht angehört, das ist das erste Mal jetzt.
Go go.
Viel Spaß mit Florentin.
Extra aus Berlin gekommen.
Siehste, kennt noch. Hier ist für euch Florentin! Ich bin jetzt vorne weg, bevor wir anfangen. Die Sache ist die, wir können momentan noch keine Witze über den Holocaust machen, deswegen ... So, alles da, okay, gut, los geht's. Ja, es ist mein erstes Mal hier auf der Senderbühne und das findet sich schon jetzt an wie ein schlechtes erstes Date. Ich stehe hier ganz alleine rum, rede viel zu viel, versuche zwei von schlechten Gags zu machen, während ihr euch denkt, mein Gott, wer hätte ich da einfach nur zu Hause. Das wäre so einfach gewesen, ich hätte nicht immer irgendwas machen müssen, ich hätte nur einfach nichts machen müssen.
Das wäre so einfach gewesen. Wie gesagt, die Dates sind wie Einradfahren.
Ich kann nicht Einradfahren. Und wirklich sehr schlecht in den ersten Dates, deswegen lese ich auch immer gern so Ratgeber,
so was kann man machen, so ein paar Tipps, so was kann man machen. Und was ich letztens gelesen habe, was Menschen besonders gut zusammenbringt,
was eine enge Verbindung herstellt, ist das gemeinsame Erleben von Extremsituationen. Und da war so eine Geschichte von so einem Mann und so einer Frau, die zusammen in so einer Röhle waren, die eingestürzt waren, die haben zusammen überlebt und haben dann auch geheiratet und sind glücklich geworden. Ja, okay, wie genau soll ich jetzt diesen Tipp umsetzen, was genau soll ich da machen? Also wie stellt es sich das vor, da gehe ich dann im Büro zu meinem Schwaben und sage so, hey, pass mal auf, wir haben doch gerade so nett am Kupieren gebetet, du hast mir erzählt, dass du wieder mehr Bongo spielen willst wie in der Kindheit. Und die Kind ist vielleicht ein bisschen verrückt, aber hast du vielleicht Lust, am Wochenende mit mir eine ausliegende Seilbahn zu fahren oder so? Und dann hast du da vorkommen. Naja, nee, aber von der Frau habe ich letztens gehört, was ich immer mache, beim zweiten Date trage ich kein Make-up mehr, um zu sehen, ob der Mann auch trotzdem noch freundlich zu mir ist. Da habe ich gesagt, das ist ein geniales Idee, das ist eine super Idee, das mache ich auch. Und zwar mache ich jetzt immer folgendes, beim zweiten Date kaufe ich mir ganz oft dieselbe Hose in unterschiedlichen Grössen, und dann gehe ich auf das Date und so alle halbe Stunde sage ich, ich muss ganz kurz aufs Klo gehen, gehe kurz weg und ziehe mir die Hose in einer Nummer klein an. Sodass es im Verlauf des Dates so wirkt, als will ich immer und immer fetter werden. Einfach um zu sehen, wo ist die Schmerzgrenze der Frau, wo geht's auf, wo hin kann ich gehen und wo bin ich weiter. Und selbst wenn sie es bis zur letzten Hose durchhält. Dann entschuldige ich mich noch mal ganz kurz, ich muss ganz kurz aufs Klo, geht kurz weg und dann bringe ich statt mir mein mexikanisches Stuntdugel raus, einfach um zu sehen, würde sie mich noch mögen, wenn ich Mexikaner wäre. Das ist für mich einfach extrem wichtig. Wie jeder, der gerade in der Beziehung ist, kann sich mal die Frage stellen, würde mich mein Partner noch lieben, wenn ich Mexikaner wäre. Dann kommen gleich paar Antworten zu. Ja, es lief nicht so gut, zum Beispiel die Mexikaner war meine letzte Freundin, die hat nicht so gut funktioniert, wir haben jetzt Schluss gemacht, aber sie war auch ein bisschen komisch, muss ich sagen, sie hatte so ein paar komische Angewohnheiten, zum Beispiel hat sie beim Obst immer mit den Aufkleber gegessen und das Obst weggegessen. War irgendwie ein bisschen seltsam. Ähm, jetzt, jetzt haben wir Schluss gemacht, ich bin jetzt auf der Summe nach einer neuen Freundin. Und ich sag mal so, das Problem ist, ich kann mir momentan die Tattoo-Entfernung nicht leisten. Das heisst, es wäre ganz gut, wenn die neue auch wieder Melanie heißen würde. Falls eine Melanie im Raum ist, einfach stellt euch an die Schlange an. Ja, das war schon ein bisschen schade, wir kannten uns schon sehr lange, wir kannten uns schon seit der Schulzeit.
Und es ist mir letztens eingefallen, dass wir in der Roma-Stufe manchmal Unterricht hatten, in einem anderen Klassenzimmer von fremden Klassen, zum Beispiel in so einer sechsten Klasse hatten wir Unterricht. Und da hingen dann an der Wand so lauter Steckbriefe von den ganzen Schülern dieser sechsten Klasse. Dann haben wir mal angeschaut, dann haben wir so Steckbriefe von so einem ganz süssen kleinen Mädchen, so Alter, Name, Clara, Dinge, die ich mag, Spaghetti, Pferde, Hasen, Dinge, die ich nicht mag, Jungs, Hausaufgaben, Spinat und Hitler. Also die Hitler, die mag ich nicht einfach, obwohl ganz technisch gesehen hätte sie Hitler gar nicht mehr erwähnen müssen, denn sie hatte ja schon einen Jung-Serie. Also eigentlich wäre das gar nicht mehr möglich gewesen. Diesen Hitler mag ich nicht, den finde ich irgendwie eklig. Und die reden immer nur über so doofen Jungs-Sachen wie Fussball oder Holocaust. Das mag ich nicht. Vielen Dank, danke schön, schönen Abend noch. Chloris-Pie-V! Oh, das tut so weh. Ja. Das tut so weh.
Aber, ja, es wurde tatsächlich bei beiden gegen Ende besser irgendwie, aber ich hatte es wirklich auch besser in Erinnerung.
Aber ich fand es so lustig, dass deine Feedlines oft besser ankamen als deine Fans.
Ja.
Da haben Leute gelacht im Publikum.
Und ich will jetzt nicht schlecht reden, aber es haben oft, es ist eine Frau, die hat penetrant gelacht bei dir.
Ja, meine Mutter.
Und es war diese eine Frau. Deine Mutter. Und oft war es die, also die hat penetrant gelacht bei dir. Ja, meine Mutter. Diese eine Frau.
Deine Mutter.
Und oft war das die.
Also die hat man sehr oft rausgehört.
Aber ich hatte auch tatsächlich die Reaktionen größer in Erinnerung tatsächlich.
Ich hatte aber diese ein bisschen schwächer in Erinnerung.
Was eigentlich perfekt unsere beiden Persönlichkeiten definiert, aber wirklich perfekt einfach.
Ja, ich saß vor allem bei dir, bei deinem Auftritt ja hinten, bei den anderen Comedians und bei den Kollegen, wie man ja jetzt sagen kann. Und diese werten Kollegen, die haben an echt anderen Stellen gelacht. Bei dir zum Beispiel fanden die den Hitler mit dem Jungs-Gag super, also dass sie theoretisch schon nach Jungs hätte aufhören können. Da haben die sich beömmelt. Also hat zumindest einer mal gesagt, der Kellner hat gesagt, ja, ist ganz okay, habe ich so noch nicht gehört. Er hat einen lustigen Tweet auf seinem iPhone gelesen. Ja, ich habe tatsächlich, muss ich natürlich auch sagen, viele Tweets recycelt, weil ich tatsächlich auch einfach scheiße faul bin und auch am Tag davor irgendwie noch nicht wirklich was hatte, aber ein paar Ideen hatte und die dann noch eingebaut haben.
Das stimmt nicht, du hattest alles schon Tage davor,
hast alles umgeschmissen halt.
Naja, nee, das stimmt nicht. Ich hatte viele
Ideen, hab dann aber, als ich mich
am Tag davor hingesetzt habe, um die auszuformulieren,
gemerkt, okay, das ist alles überhaupt nicht lustig,
das funktioniert alles gar nicht
und muss dann noch ein bisschen was stopfen, aber naja.
Na gut, ich hab auch Geschichten genommen, die ich
schon mal erzählt hab hier im Podcast und versucht hab, aber ich glaube, ich habe die Form umformuliert teilweise. Aber man muss sagen, es war tatsächlich echt ein geiles Gefühl. Also es war immer, auf der Bühne zu stehen und wenn dann, also bei mir hat der erste schon überhaupt gar nicht funktioniert. Tatsächlich, es hat recht lange gedauert, bis zum ersten Nachhinein bei dir hat Stefan Fancy für Starr, ist natürlich ein Klasse, kann man gut machen. Gut, aber es ist dann schon echt unangenehm, wenn keine Lacher kommen. Aber sobald dann die ersten Lacher kommen und man auch so ein bisschen lockerer wird und sich wohlfühlt und denkt, okay, ich habe jetzt noch einiges zu erzählen und die Kompens sind auch ganz gut dabei, es ist echt ein geiles Gefühl, das muss man echt sagen. Das ist mir ja geil, ja. Man wird echt immer lockerer und man hat irgendwie auch einfach keine Lust mehr aufzuhören. Es ist echt wie so ein Rausch, du hast die Aufmerksamkeit von dem ganzen Raum. da sind 50 Leute, die nur dir zuhören gerade und nichts anderes machen und du stehst gerade voll im Mittelpunkt, Licht auf dich, alles andere ist dunkle. Ja, und vor allem Lachen ist eine viel geilere Anerkennung, eine viel geilere Form der Anerkennung, als zum Beispiel Klatschen oder so. Total. Das kann man auch höflich, aber Lachen machst du halt nur, du kannst nicht cool unecht lachen und ein Publikum lacht auch nicht unecht. Ja, und auf der Aufnahme hört man jetzt nur das Lachen, aber es ist ja auch so eine Atmosphäre. Und du schaust auch ins Publikum, die dich halt vielleicht, manche Leute grinsen halt nur oder lachen jetzt halt nicht immer. Und du guckst da und die freuen sich irgendwie und gucken dich an und du haust da Sachen raus. Das ist schon echt ganz cool. Das ist mega geil. Es ist auch wie eine Sucht irgendwie. Man hat, man ist danach auch, man hat irgendwie so Entzugserscheinungen danach. Danach fühlt man sich total Adrenalin wieder runter und man fühlt sich fast schlechter als davor, weil man diesen High hatte einfach. Das ist schon echt sehr wichtig. Ja und vor allem, man muss auch mal sagen, die anderen Comedians kamen teilweise auch nicht besser an und die haben halt schon mehrere Auftritte da gemacht so. Und das finde ich total interessant, weil die haben dann oft neues Material ausprobiert. Und man muss sagen, das ist glaube ich das Geilste überhaupt, wenn du wirklich am Tag noch da vorbeigehen kannst und der dir sagt, mach entweder fünf Minuten oder eine Viertelstunde und du kannst wirklich, du hast genug Programm, um flexibel zu sein, wie viel du gerade machst. Das finde ich, Wenn man so weit ist, dass man eine Viertelstunde machen kann
und nur fünf Minuten oder theoretisch eine halbe Stunde aus dem Steh greift,
das finde ich so grossartig, und da will ich auf jeden Fall immer hinkommen.
Also, ich würde das auf jeden Fall noch mal machen.
Wir haben auch schon ein paar Kontakte da geknüpft,
unter anderem bei dem, der zwischen uns aufgetreten ist,
der hat auch eine eigene Show.
Ja, aber dann natürlich unter anderem Namen. Also, wenn dann irgendwo in eurer Nähe ein Teffernstitze und Borentin Bill auftritt, dann geht da lieber nicht hin. Wir haben jetzt noch genau Platz für eine Anekdote und ich würde mir wünschen, dass sie gut wäre. Okay. Also hast du noch eine Gute am Start? Nee. Ich hätte noch Kleinigkeiten am Start. Zum Beispiel habe ich gelesen, dass wir besprochen wurden, dass dieser Podcast besprochen wurde irgendwo. Ja, da habe ich auch gelesen. Da hat jemand geschrieben, ich habe das Podcast-Ufo bei mir auf der Seite besprochen. Und dann bin ich da draufgeklickt, weil ich von diesem Wort besprochen so fasziniert war. Da hat jemand einen Absatz über uns geschrieben und ich war enttäuscht. Und ganz im Ernst. Es ist so eins unter analysieren, so besprochen, ich habe drüber gesprochen. Ganz im fucking ernst. Ich finde, also die Linguisten, die haben ja eh nicht mehr so viel zu tun. Also es gibt ja die meisten Wörter, gibt es ja schon. Und wenn man noch Wörter braucht, dann setzt man halt Dinge zusammen, die es schon gibt. Oder man erfindet Namen. Aber das wird ja nicht mehr so viel gebraucht. Deswegen könnte es sich mal die Arbeit machen, bei jedem Wort eine klarere Definition dahinter zu schreiben, wie zum Beispiel, man darf nur besprochen schreiben, wenn man mindestens fünf Argumente liefert oder so. Oder mindestens fünf Aspekte bringt. Das wäre nicht blöd so eine Sprachpolizei, das wäre nicht geschlecht, gegen den Missbrauch von Worten. Aber voll, genau, du darfst auch nicht, genau, auch sowas, die jetzt Wörter und Worte, das klar zu trennen und einfach genau die Definition hinzunahlen, so richtig nazihaft einfach die Definition zu schreiben.
So komplex und kompliziert.
Ich will Zahlen in Sprache haben. Ab vier darfst du sagen, analysieren, Argumenten, ab fünf Beispielen darfst du sagen, du hast es besprochen, aber nicht bei einem kümmerlichen Absatz, weil du erweckst Erwartungen mit sowas und auch Zeitungen müssen viel vorsichtiger sein. Das finde ich großartig. Das ist ein Zitat der Folge. Auch Zeitungen müssen der letzte Mahner Deutschlands, Stefan Tingo, hat gesprochen. Auch Zeitungen müssen vorsichtiger sein heutzutage. Aus einem ganz anderen Grund. Sie benutzen das Wort Gefühle, wenn sie eigentlich Emotionen meinen, das darf so nicht weitergehen. Genau das meine ich, das ist genau der Punkt. Auch wir würden uns auch quasi total das eigene Bein schneiden damit. Ich finde es schon ganz geil, dass wir besprochen wurden und unsere einzige Reaktion darauf ist, warum wurden wir nicht mehr besprochen? Das Erste, was kommt sofort. Unsere Reaktion ist eigentlich, warum wurden wir nicht besprochen, obwohl da steht, dass wir besprochen wurden. Warum wurden wir belogen? Warum müssen wir das über uns ergehen? Genau, nicht sozusagen. Es hat uns niemand besprochen und unsere Reaktion ist, warum wurden wir belogen? Finde ich auch gut. Ja, ich habe jetzt noch so ein paar Ideen, aber die würde ich gerne einfach nochmal für die nächste Folge mir überlegen. Die rauszuhören. Ich finde es so gut, dass wir mittlerweile überhaupt nicht mehr versuchen, irgendwie ein organisches Gespräch zu bauen. Saja, ich hätte jetzt noch drei mittlere Ideen und eine nicht so gut. Aber wann ist das eigentlich gekippt? Sollen wir es wieder in den Griff bekommen eigentlich, dass wir mal wieder ein normales, organisches? Ich glaube, das ist mit diesem Schnittmassaker gekippt irgendwann. Welches Schnittmassaker meinst du? Das stimmt nicht. Nee, aber es ist ja irgendwann so ein Bewusstsein aufgekommen, dass wir schneien können und dass wir nicht immer sofort performen müssen. Und früher war es halt so, während der andere gesprochen hat, musste man halt konstant überlegen, okay, was sag ich als nächstes, was sag ich als nächstes, weil es darf keine Pause entstehen. Mittlerweile ist es so, ach scheiß auf die Pause, mal gucken, ob er was sagt, ansonsten atmen wir einfach noch was zu kommen. Nee, so nehme ich das nicht wahr, aber bei Skype ist halt extrem so. Nein, das hat mir das jetzt kein Zitul. Nee mit den letzten Wochen, wo wir gegenüber voneinander saßen, haben wir das ja auch nicht gemacht. Aber seitdem wir das bei Skype wieder machen, ich zum Beispiel höre dich die ganze Zeit, als würdest du durch ein Walkie-Talkie mit mir sprechen. Und da du aber nie Over oder so sagst, weil ich nicht, wann aus ist mit Reden. Jetzt zum Beispiel redest du, jetzt redest du gerade und ich weiß nicht, worauf reagierst du gerade, auf was, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Ich fand den Scherenmann auf jeden Fall auch sehr lustig und ich glaube, den kannst du noch niemals wieder machen. Nee, weil ich liege gerade in der Badewanne mit dem Walkie-Talkie und das andere Walkie-Talkie liegt so auf so einem Stativ vorm Mikrofon gerade. Was ihr nicht wisst, wir nehmen mit einem Dosen-Telefon auf. Genau, Dosen direkt an die Podcast-Zentrale. Wir kommunizieren in einer langen Schnur von Köln nach Berlin und zwei Dosen. Wir waren sogar kurz davor, unsere Podcast-Lizenz zu verlieren, wegen dieser Scherengeschichte. Da haben wir ein paar ganz ernste Blicke aus dem Leben. Wir wohnen ja direkt neben der Podcast-Zentrale, neben der Podcast HQ. Und da haben schon ein paar Leute sehr skeptisch rübergeguckt über den Zaun. Podcast-Polizei. Und schon so den Finger in der Luft gehabt, so na na na. Das fände ich auch nicht schlecht. Na na na. Wenn es eine Podcast-Polizei gäbe, die sich immer dann in Folgen ankündigt mit so einem ja hallo wir sind die Podcast-Polizei, ich habe letzte Woche was von Scheren erzählt, Entschuldigung ähm, was ich auch interessant finde, wir haben jetzt ja den neuen diesen explicit button haben wir ja jetzt ja, jetzt so, ticken, ficken und ficken Bullshit,ödmann, wir können die ganzen Stimmen Sachen jetzt sagen, und als wir besprochen wurden, du doofe Rübe, als wir besprochen wurden, stand da drin, das Podcast-Ufo trägt den Explicit-Button mit Stolz und zu Recht. Seit fünf Minuten. Da sagte ich mir, ich lese das, ich bin ein Teil dieses Podcasts, ich wusste noch nicht mal, dass wir den haben. Das ist auch so ein Ding. Wir wurden auch noch falsch besprochen, falsch verstanden. Das ist immer das Schönste, wenn man andere Leute liest, die was über das sagen, was man hundertprozentig sicher weiß. Was man besser weiß als die Leute, die darüber schreiben, ja. Weil die Medien ja immer so ein Ding sind, wir beziehen das Wissen ja aus Medien, aber wenn die Medien das Wissen von einem selber beziehen und man es selber weiß, bin ich das so großartig immer, weil es nicht stimmt. Ja, vor allem den Medien wird er wirklich nicht vertraut. Und ich lese das oft so bei einem Neomagazin-Video, das dann in den YouTube-Kommentaren, bei Spielen dann so, ja, die wussten die Antworten noch alle schon im Vorhinein, das war alle abgekaterte Spiel, da sieht man, dass Jan irgendwie viel zu schnell reagiert und du weißt einfach, nein, es ist einfach nicht so, du weißt es einfach, aber die streiten sich dann, nein, das stimmt nicht, doch, das kann man ja alles schneiden und die haben das bestimmt im Vorhinein besprochen und so und ich bin mir ganz sicher und es war bei dem und dem Spiel schon so und du weißt auch, nee, ist einfach nicht so. Nein, es ist nicht so. Das ist echt so interessant, weil man ja selber auch manchmal so Meinungen hat über Folgen, so ja, das ist alles gefakt und so, aber wahrscheinlich hat man genauso unrecht, wie die Leute da. Ja, ja, genau.
Weil man immer so schnell dabei ist zu sagen, das ist alles gefakt, das ist alles falsch, aber viele Dinge sind. Ja, man sucht immer so einen großen Komplex, aber im Prinzip ist alles Ockhams Rasiermesser. Es ist die möglichst, die einfachste Antwort ist immer die richtige. Das ist nicht Ockhams Rasiermesser. Bis zum nächsten Mal, liebe Kinder, mach's gut. Jetzt sind wir schon wieder bei Rasiermessern gelandet am Ende. Ich fasse es nicht. Ja, es wird nicht, wir drehen uns einfach immer im Kreis. Wir kriegen es nicht hin. Nächste Folge, dann mit ... Ach so, warte mal. Wollen wir kurz mal teasen auf die neue Projektidee? Home Story? Hm? Nee, wir werden auf die Home Story. Okay, dann teasen Ist die Homestory schon nächste Woche? Ah, zwölfte.
Nee, warte mal. Und da steht jetzt fest, der zwölfte, oder was?
Wollte man das nicht verschieben?
Ja, musst du mir sagen.
Ich fände eher in Richtung Weihnachten schön.
Ein bisschen später.
Ja, ja, aber dann machen wir doch.
Aber in der Woche ist doch nichts mehr, oder?
Neomagazin-mäßig.
Ja, aber Samstag ist doch nicht mehr.
Es driftet in private Gespräche ab.
Es ist jetzt einfach nur noch ein privates Gespräch.
Ja, aber in der Woche ist doch kein Neom New Magazin mehr, ne? Weiß ich nicht. Dann lasst doch das in der Woche machen. Und freut euch auf jeden Fall auf die nächste Folge, die wird ganz fantastisch mit einem neuen Projekt, denn wir launchen die, das Podcast-UFO Home Story. Hey, ganz recht, wie wir es damals in Folge 9 angekündigt haben, werden wir die nächste Folge bei einem Hörer zu Hause aufnehmen. Eine nette Hörerin hat uns eingeladen, bei ihr vorbeizukommen und dort einen Podcast aufzunehmen. Das nehmen wir natürlich an und wir kommen vorbei und haben vielleicht tatsächlich unseren ersten weiblichen Gast in der Sendung, eine Hörerin. Wir haben vielleicht unser erstes Mal live, bei einer Hörerin, vor dem Mikro. Und falls ihr noch Tipps habt, irgendwas, was wir wissen müssen, einfach nochmal in die Kommentare schreiben. Wir sind sehr aufnahmefähig, was das angeht. Also ich glaube, sie hat uns vor allem mit dem Argument Kakao gelockt, und es ist ja auch diese behagliche Weihnachtsstimmung, die wir beide empfinden gerade. Und wir wollen einfach mal jetzt irgendwen so ein warmes Gefühl ums Herz bescheren. Und wir haben noch ein ganz tolles anderes Projekt für euch am Start, was vielleicht nächstes Jahr gelauncht wird. Wir haben schon ein paar Mal darüber gesprochen, aber es wird bald konkret. Die krassen Hörer von euch wissen vielleicht, worum es geht. Wir werden in der nächsten Folge mal ein bisschen mehr darauf teasen. Wir werden jetzt so ein bisschen so Adventskalendermässig immer so ein bisschen mehr verraten. Und so ein bisschen, so jede Folge so ein bisschen mehr darauf hinteasen, bis es im nächsten Jahr dann den großen Knall gibt. Ich bin echt so nervös gerade, weil ich freue mich so auf meine drei Türchen Adventskalender. Das ist so geil, dass man nur einmal einen Tag und dann drei gleichzeitig essen. Wie geil ist das denn? Ja, aber du denk mal an gestern vielleicht. Gestern war ein trauriger Tag, weil du konntest nichts essen. Ich glaube, ich kaufe mir einfach direkt zwei. Oder, was ich auch gesehen habe, jemand hat sich 24 Adventskalender gekauft und isst einfach jeden Tag einen ganzen Adventskalender. War das nicht die Idee, jede Stunde bis Weihnachten was zu essen zu haben? Ja, 24 kann man natürlich natürlich auch machen. Du hast pro Tag eine Wärtskennende mit 24 Dingen.
Du musst halt durchgehend wach bleiben, das ist halt der Nachteil.
So halt wach bis Weihnachten.
Aber dafür ist es sehr praktisch, dass Weihnachten am 24. ist und nicht am 25.
Da wird das Ganze nicht aufgehen.
Naja, ich wünsche euch noch eine schöne Woche.
Mit diesem Funfact verabschieden wir uns. Bis zum nächsten Mal, wenn es wieder heisst.